in the last video we figure out how to
figure out the sum of the roots of a
polynomial what we're going to try to
attempt to do in this video is think
about the sum of the squares of the
roots of a polynomial so let's think
about that a little bit so let's say
that I have a second degree polynomial
that looks like this so it's x squared
plus a 1 X plus a 2 and this is equal to
0 we saw in an octree I'll just redo
some of what we did in the last video
because it's going to be useful over
here this thing is going to have two
roots r1 and r2 two roots and that tells
us that this thing can be rewritten as X
minus r1 times X minus r2 is equal to
zero and if you expand this out you get
x squared minus r1 plus r2 r1 plus r2 x
plus r1 r2 so that's what you get right
over there now let's think about it we
figured out from the last video that r1
plus r2 we figured out that r1 plus r2
which is right over here that needs to
be equal to the negative of this
coefficient this a 1 over here is equal
to the negative of r1 plus r2 so r1 plus
r2 is equal to the negative of a 1 is
equal to the negative of a 1 so let's
see if we can use that information right
over there to figure out what to figure
out let me do this in a new color to
figure out what R 1 squared plus r2
squared is so let's see how we could get
that well one place that we could start
off with we could start off with r1 plus
r2 squared so r1 plus r2 squared which
is of course the same thing as negative
a1 squared which would be the same thing
as a1 squared a 1 squared I could put a
negative here but a negative 1 times
negative 1 is obviously a positive 1
this is going to be equal to r1 squared
plus 2 r1 r2 plus r2 squared so this has
the sum that we care about in it let's
call this let me call this over here
let's call this sum
one we're just raising the roots to the
first power let's call this over here
let's call this some two so this over
here we've written essentially that
someone squared that sum S sub 1 squared
is equal to this Plus this is S sub 2 is
equal to s sub 2 plus 2 R 1 R 2 so plus
plus 2 R 1 R 2 now can we figure out
what R 1 R 2 is based on looking at the
actual original polynomial
well you look over here if you just did
an expansion of course I forgot to write
here that this is equal to 0 R 1 R 2 R 1
R 2 is in is essentially represented by
a 2 over here it's represented so to
take the first degree sum or the the
roots raised to the first power
something we looked at this coefficient
now of a sudden we're involving the
coefficient to the right of that we're
going to degrees below the degree of the
polynomial so this right over here is a
2 so R 1 R 2 is a 2 that's a 2 this
right here this right here this whole
expression is a 1 squared so if we want
to solve for this sum if we want to
solve for S sub 2 we would get S sub 2
is equal to a 1 squared a 1 squared
that's this over here minus -2 times a
sub 2 so we just figured out a fast way
to figure out the sum of the squares of
the roots of a just a second-degree
quadratic right now so for example if I
were to give you if I were to give you
let me give you something strange so if
I were to give you 7x squared minus pi X
plus E is equal to 0 and someone said I
want you to figure out the squares the
sum of the squares of the roots of this
polynomial first you want to make this
the coefficient in front of the x
squared 1 so divide everything by 7 so
you get x squared minus PI over 7
x plus e over 7 is equal to 0 and then
you can just use the result we just
found thus the sum of the square of the
root is this s2 over here whatever the
roots are you square each of them you
take their sum it's going to be equal to
a 1 squared so it's going to be pi
squared over 49 I'm just squaring this
right over here or I can just square
that the negative doesn't matter when
I'm squaring minus 2 times this minus 2
times e over 7 and that's about as
simplified as you can get this
expression so it's PI squared over 49
minus 2 e over 7 which is by itself a
pretty neat result because it would be
very hard to find the roots of this you
get some crazy numbers and then you'd
have to square them and sum them but we
just figured out a very fast way of
doing it now let's see if we can extend
this to the third degree in it actually
turns out you can not only to the third
degree you can extend this to the nth
degree and I might do an induction proof
it gets a little bit messier than when
you just take the first degree sum right
over here we take the sum of the roots
to the first power but let's just see if
it works for let's see if it works for
the third power so let's say I have the
polynomial X to the third plus a1 x
squared plus a 2 X plus a 3 is equal to
zero we have three roots r1 r2 r3 which
tells us that we can rewrite this
polynomial as X minus or this equation
is X minus r1 times X minus r2 times X
minus X minus r3 is equal to 0 now we
already figured out we already figured
out what this part right here is it's
this thing over here we already
multiplied it out it's this thing it is
this over here so essentially to get
this whole expression we just have to
multiply this times this thing over here
so we're essentially just use the
distributive property multiply this
thing times each of these terms
so first let's multiply this whole thing
by X so you get X to the third X to the
third minus r1 plus r2 times x squared
plus r1
r2x so I just multiplied this thing over
here times X now I can just multiply
this thing up here times negative R 3 so
negative R 3 times x squared so it's
negative R 3 x squared negative R 3
times this term over here gives us it
will give us what's going to be a
negative times a negative so it's going
to be a positive so it's positive R
three times this we can distribute them
we're going to get R 1 R 1 so let me
make sure I'm doing negative R 3 times
this over here is going to be negative
let me just write it like this negative
I don't want to skip steps Oneg going to
be the negative and the negative cancel
out so negative r 3 times R 1 plus R 2 X
and then finally you have the negative R
3 times R 1 R 2 so minus R 1 R 2 R 3 and
all that's going to be equal to 0 but
let's simplify it so this thing is going
to be equal to X to the third minus R 1
plus R 2 plus R 3 we did that in the
last video that shows us that the sum of
our roots is this second coefficient
here the coefficient on the second
degree term x squared and then we go
over here we have R 1 R 2 X so plus R 1
R 2 X then you have R 1 R 3 x plus R 1 R
3 I'm just distributing this and then
you have R 3 times R 2 so plus R 2 R 3
all of that times X and then minus R 1 R
2 and R 3 now if we want to take the sum
of the squares of the roots so if we
want to take R 1 squared plus R 2
squared plus R 3 squared well we could
try to do the same thing we could take R
1 plus R 2 plus R 3 which we know how to
calculate we can square that and we're
essentially going to get when you when
you square this you're going to get let
me see if I can write it neatly this is
going to be equal to the R 1 times so
I'm just going to let me just read
this is equal to just to clarify this is
equal to R 1 plus R 2 plus R 3 times R 1
plus R 2 plus R 3 so it's going to be I
can start over here R 1 times R 1 is R 1
squared plus R 1 times R 2 so R 1 R 2
plus R 1 times R 3 R 1 times R 3 and
then plus now we're in the R 2 R 2 times
R 1 is plus R 1 R 2 same thing I'm just
switching the order so it looks the same
R 2 times R 2 is R 2 squared and then r2
times r3 is plus R 2 R 3 and then let's
go to the R 3 R 3 times R 1 is just
another R 3 R 1 I just switch the order
R 3 times R 2 is another R 2 R 3 and
then R 3 times R 3 is R 3 squared so
what do we just get here when we squared
just the straight up some you got you
got R 1 squared plus r2 squared plus R 3
squared plus u Sencha Li got all of the
different combinations but you got them
twice you have 2 r 1 r 2 so you have 2
times R 1 R 2 R 1 R 2 then you have 2 R
1 s r3 so plus r1 r3 you have the 2 out
front plus R 2 R 3 R 2 R 3 and this over
here is equal to remember what we did
this is equal to R 1 plus R 2 plus R 3
squared so we got essentially the same
result remember this thing right over
here let's make things clear this thing
over here R 1 R all the combinations of
the products of the roots if you look
over here that's exactly what this thing
is over here which must be what our a 2
coefficient is so this is our a 2
coefficient this R 1 plus R 2 plus R 3
that is we figured out multiple times
that's this thing right over here which
is going to be a 1 so this is going to
be a negative or it's equal to negative
a 1 but you take negative a1 squared
that's the same thing is a one squared
so this is a one squared and this is the
sum that we care about this is the sum
that we care about so we get we get r1
squared + r2 squared plus r3 squared is
equal to this business over here it's
equal to a 1 squared minus 2 minus 2
times a 2 so we got the exact same
result we got the exact same result that
we got for the second-degree case and it
actually turns out this will be true of
any degree I haven't proven to yes
although I can make an induction
argument now we've proven some base
cases but just to make it clear how to
apply it
I give you crazy polynomial I gave you
let's do a third-degree case let's let's
say 10 X to the third minus 5 x squared
plus 7x I'm making this up on the fly
plus 2 plus 2 is equal to 0 and if I
were to ask you the sum if I were to ask
you are one squared plus r2 squared plus
r3 squared if I were to ask you the
square of the sum of the roots
you just take the firt you just take
well let me be careful you have to make
sure that you have a 1 in front of the
highest degree term so this thing over
here has to be rewritten divide both
sides by 10 X to the third minus 5 over
10 so minus 1/2 x squared plus 7 over 10
X plus 2 over 10 which is 1/5 is equal
to 0 so I just divided both sides by 10
and yep I did that part right and now we
can apply this as I almost made a
careless mistake you have to have a 1
coefficient out here at least the way
that we've derived this so this sum is
going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to a 1 squared so
this you could 1/2 squared so a 1 is
what a 1 is actually negative 1/2 but
negative 1/2 squared is just 1/4 so it
is going to be 1/4 minus minus 2 times a
2 minus 2 times a 2 so minus 2
times 7 over 10 so this is equal to 1/4
1/4 minus minus 14 over 10 minus 14 over
10 we could find a common denominator
this is the same thing as 5 5 over 25
over 20 minus 14 over 10 and this is
equal or sorry minus 28 over 20 I should
do minus 28 over 20 which is equal to
negative 23 over 20 and you might say
hey Sal hang on I'm taking the square of
a bunch of roots and adding them up and
I'm getting a negative number
I thought squares I thought when I
square numbers I always get a positive
number that would be true if you're
dealing with real numbers but remember
the roots of a polynomial can be complex
and complex numbers squared can be
negative numbers so this obviously is
involving some type of complex roots but
we know that the sum when you take the
sum of the squares of those complex
roots you get negative 23 over 20